all right today we are talking about
irresistible juicy can't not click it
subject lines that's right we're going
to Skyrocket those open rates for you
and I'm going to do that by giving you
my
5c framework okay you'll never have to
guess again whether your subject line is
going to do well or not do well based on
this framework okay so let's eliminate
the guesswork and Dive Right In actually
before we dive in could you do me just a
b very quick favor go ahead and like And
subscribe okay like this video subscribe
to the channel it helps us so so so much
and if you stick around to the end I've
got a gift for you okay so all right now
that we've got that out of the way now
let's Dive Right In with the first of
our 5 C's okay everything's going to be
C that's why it's called the 5c
framework the first of our 5c's is the
most important the crema creme and if
there's anything that you don't use in
this video but you only use this one C
you will win and that first C is
curiosity okay curiosity is one of the
most powerful drugs in human psychology
that you can use to leverage your
subject lines okay when you target your
audience with something that they are
genuinely curious about right they will
click they can't not click or they'll be
thinking about it all day long let me
give you some examples here's an example
of a object line that I wrote for a farm
targeting health conscious families moms
dads with kids okay health conscious
families all right the subject line is
this one food replaces eight supplements
okay this one food replaces eight
supplements notice that I didn't give it
away healthc conscious people are on the
other side saying I take a lot of
supplements right I did my research and
know that they buy a lot of supplements
and so when I say something that
replaces a bunch of supplements things
that they're spending a lot of money on
they're curious they're like oh my gosh
what is that so this one food replaces
eight supplements great little curiosity
hooked to get that market to open that
email here's another one now this one I
sent to my personal list who is as you
know right full of copywriters so a
bunch of copywriters on here here's a
subject line that I sent to you guys
disturbing things I do to drive open
open rates disturbing things I do to
drive open rate I mean you can't not be
curious with that one it's like what
does he do to drive open rates right
like if you are an email copywriter you
want to know what I do to drive open
rates so that is curiosity let me give
you a third one before we move on to our
next C the number one mistake
copywriters make in emails the number
one mistake copywriters making emails
okay this has the negative curiosity
twist in it where it's like oh my gosh
what am I doing wrong what am I doing
wrong to where I'm twisting it on them
that they should open it because they
might be doing something really bad okay
and so again keep this all in mind this
is dedicated to your Market if I would
say the number one mistake that
copywriters do in email to the farm
people the health conscious people they
wouldn't they couldn't care less right
that doesn't work for them they don't
care at all so you have to cater these
to your Market but that wraps up curios
okay curiosity being the first of the 5c
framework the second one of the 5c
framework is crazy okay crazy if you
have a crazy subject line is this
accomplishes what Ben settle calls the
dirty milk test okay the dirty milk test
meaning your copy your subject line
whatever it is shouldn't taste look feel
or smell like anything else right if you
get dirty milk in the fridge you're like
oh my God that's like it's potent right
it it cuts through all the noise of
everything else in the fridge well your
email subject line the crazy version
cuts through all the noise in the inbox
now let me give you some examples of
what I'm talking about I got robbed by a
pastor that's a true story not clickbait
I've told it in my email many times if
you've been on my list I got robbed by a
p that's crazy that's it you can't not
do that and it's curiosity it teases a
story there's all kinds of just juice
riddled into that subject line that is
one of my highest opening rates in there
because pastors don't Rob people that's
that's great well this one did and if I
ever find that guy any who let me give
you another example okay this one is
straight from Sensei settle Ben settle
okay hat tip all right this one is one
of his most famous bizarre crazy subject
lines Phantom pooping prospects okay if
you read Phantom pooping prospects one
of his most famous subject lines people
talk about it all the time so that's a
great one the third one how about this
one I used this one a couple months ago
crazy open rates Google is trying to
murder email marketers okay so when I I
could say things like Google doesn't
care for email marketers or Google is
eliminating rules that her email
marketer like you could say those things
but I cranked it up a notch and said
Google is trying to murder email
marketers so now you take an average or
subject line and you crank up the dial
and you turn it crazy and people just
can't ignore it now one rule of thumb is
use The Crazy Ones sparingly like if you
do crazy every day it becomes
unbelievable people are like ah this
guy's just bull crapping me right you
you don't want to use these ones too
often as opposed to the first SE
curiosity you could use that every day
all day twice a day three times a day
forever and never have to change
anything right curiosity is forever but
you want to mix things up a bit crazy is
a great way to mix things up a bit all
right number three of our 5c framework
is
challenge challenge existing Dogma okay
the challenge is you want to take a
mindset that your Market has and you
want to give them an opportunity to
think differently about that mindset
okay let me give you some examples of
what I'm talking about here's one that I
wrote to email marketers copywriters to
my email list why you should never pitch
your work again okay that is challenging
existing Dogma because email copywriters
pitch their work all the time right
they're always reaching out to clients
and here's what I can do for you blah
blah blah all these things and so I'm
actually challenging this mindset that's
been embedded in the culture like
pitching is fine that that's how you
land clients right you pitch your work
you connect with them and I'm telling
you you should never do that and why
hurt so I'm giving them an opportunity
to think differently now here's the
caveat to subject lines like this is a
lot of people will write a subject line
like this and then they make a cardinal
sin in the email copyrighting world that
cardinal sin is called betraying the
subject line what that means is they'll
write a subject line like this that
challenges existing dogma and then when
you get into the email it really doesn't
challenge it at all in fact it just
gives you some hokey version of why your
original thinking is correct in this new
style of thinking is not correct that's
called betraying the subject line if you
do that you will lose trust with your
people so you want to make sure that you
challenge existing dogma and you have
proof to back up that your subject line
is actually what you genuinely meant to
say okay so that's a little bit of
disclaimer word a warning on the
challenge C let me give you another
example how to make more money by firing
your clients okay again uh very very
much in kind of the same vein about not
pitching your work but this one
is even more emotional cuz now I'm
talking about making more money and
firing people instead of getting more
clients right everybody's talking about
you got to get more clients you make so
much money blah blah blah right like all
that stuff I'm saying the opposite
here's how to make more money by firing
your clients and then I walk through how
you actually do that passive income
things like that but that's I mean how
could you not read it everybody wants to
fire their clients so now I'm tweaking a
desire I'm challenging their existing
thought irresistible that's an
irresistible subject line let's move on
to another example and then we'll keep
going here's one that I wrote uh again
for that farm one of my farm clients
selling meats and stuff like that five
reasons you shouldn't buy
organic five reasons you shouldn't buy
organic this one took off like the Moon
I mean people were clicking it left and
right because all over the media
everywhere organic this organic that
USDA blah blah blah so I got into their
minds and I challenged their thought
that organic is good organic blah blah
blah and I blew it up and I told them
what's really the story behind organic
so I challenge their minds I give them
an opportunity okay so that is c number
three challenge let's move on to c
number four culture c number four is
culture okay whenever you can make your
subject lines relevant to something
happening in culture or something that's
happened in culture that was you know
very notable then it makes it more
interesting because what it does it
makes your subject lines relatable right
it makes them familiar to the people
that are reading them even if it has
nothing to do with your Market that's
how much it has to be relative to the
culture now let me give you some
examples of what I'm talking about
here's one that I wrote to you guys okay
50 shades of copyrighting 50 Shades of
copyrighting that's a great that's a
great one uh that that jumps into the
idea right 50 Shades of grade it's it's
so culturally popular you could say that
in any decade and people know EXA what
you're talking about plus it has this
kind of risque connotation behind it so
it is it edges on the line it could be
crazy but it's not crazy it's just
culturally relevant to where I take that
shift it to my market and people are
like what is he talking about so that's
a culturally relevant subject line
here's another one for you George
castanza marketing Secrets okay this
one's been used by everyone like I know
five copywriters off the top of my head
that have used the George castanza thing
I think Ben settle did make it famous in
that but we've all used it and so some
sort of terminology but George castan's
a Seinfeld right culturally relevant
especially if it's with your target
audience we tie it to his marketing
secrets we talk about the show whatever
it is it's culturally relevant people
know George castanza and so when you
talk about it now you tie your Market
back to something that's relevant abroad
okay here's the last one here's the last
one how to leverage Kanye West for your
sales page everybody knows Kanye right
everybody knows Kanye crazy is in the
news and so just even putting them in
your subject line will ratchet up your
open rates because it drives curiosity
you have familiarity with it and I tied
it to my market where I talk about
writing sales Pages which most
copywriters write sales pages and so
that is how to make your subject lines
culturally relevant and drive those open
rates up and the final of the 5c
framework is credibility this one is so
freaking powerful I saved it for Less
okay if you could provide credibility
into something that you're about to say
it is one of the most powerful driving
forces not just for open rates but
actually for sales so this is already
wetting the beak to get them to click
your link and buy your product if you
open up with a credibility subject line
let me tell you what I'm talking about
okay here's an example new supplement
used by Navy Seals to build muscle fast
okay new supplement used by Navy Seals
to build muscle fast used by Navy Seals
is my credibility Factor right if I
would have just said new supplement to
build muscle
fast I I mean that's just a boring okay
subject line use supplement to build
most fast so I mean like do they really
believe that but when I say used by Navy
Seals oh my gosh has credibility behind
it now people are interested they want
to click it and they're already more apt
to buy okay here's the second one here's
one Tim Ferris number one newsletter
growth tip okay every everybody knows
Tim Ferris and so you could kind of
borrow his credibility of something he
said maybe on a podcast or whatever
which is exactly what I did he said
something about a podcast on growing his
newsletter the number one thing that he
does I borrowed that turned that into an
email used his credibility to then drive
open RS because he's relative to the
market so now you're borrowing
somebody's authority to drive your open
RS up really helpful last one last one
for credibility Pixar storytelling
Secret that you can use in your emails
okay this one's huge cuz Pixar is the
ultimate storytelling Mecca right
everybody knows Pixar for their films
for their stories and and so that
already provides you the necessary
credibility that you need to talk about
their storytelling in your emails Drive
open rates Crush sales going to
absolutely demolish your goals as an
email copywriter so that is the 5c
framework let's recap them real quick
let's look at all of them okay curiosity
number one crazy number two challenge
existing Dogma number three culture
number four and credibility number five
if you only mastered those email subject
lines you would be the Sensei of subject
lines okay and you do you want to be the
Sensei of subject lines you want to be
your own email goat in your Niche and
you want to absolutely smash it for your
audience so to wrap things up if you
enjoyed this and found this valuable
again like the video subscribe to the
channel for more content like this and
before you go I have a gift as always
check the description below for your
free 63 cash cow copyrighting tips in my
copyrighting Catalyst guide just for you
okay you jump in there it's free put
your email in I email it to you directly
you can start using it today making more
money today I hope that was helpful for
you I'll catch you on the next one that
was a good one I mean that was just
Absol Savage
George castanas marketing secret so
good five C's
genius pure genius at this
point wo I like that I like that a lot